Dr. Kowalski prepared three copies of the
February 9, 2016 edition of the New York Times
for testing.
A copy was placed on the setting 1:1, and
the output produced was one copy of the February
9, 2016 edition of the Cleveland, Ohio Plain
Dealer.
Another copy was placed on the setting "Very
Fine."
The output produced was a copy of the February
10, 2016 edition of The New York Times.
An examination of the paper revealed large
blank sections, and the final four pages were
completely blank.
The text consistently changed while being
observed, prompting researchers to hypothesize
that they were seeing the draft of the issue
appear as it was being written.